Elon Musk this cannot be overstated he
in some respects is saving Western
Society right now by allowing people to
get information directly and allowing
people to see the horrors and then also
expose the bad guys who are all too
willing to expose themselves uh we would
not have that if Elon Musk did not have
Twitter right we know that the
censorship and the Banning and all of
those things you would they would be
banning and suspending the good guys and
promoting the bad guys but some of the
bad guys are still on there and it's an
interesting philosophic debate on as to
what Elon should do about these things
but I think it is good to know uh what
some of the genuinely bad guys are
saying here is Iranian supreme leader uh
that video that he linked to before I
read the Tweet is from the uh the desert
the party where 250 Israeli kids I mean
you know teenagers and and 20 something
year olds were killed who were just
going to a a concert he wrote God
Willing the cancer of the usurper
Zionist regime will be eradicated at the
hands of the Palestinian people and the
resistance forces through the region